Hold on a second. I'd like to point out, uh,
for someone who says he doesn't like Jubilee films, he,
you gave him one on leukemia. A 10. Yeah.
Will you stick by that? Because if you do, then I can high-five you, but if not,
the backhand is coming. Okay. Um, what did I give spirited away?
Uh, let me see, because I th I think thinking back one of the, okay.
Is one of my games, spirited away at nine. Okay then. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really have to think about that because I don't like Ghibli films,
but I think Manono cane spirit of the way are some of the few where I start,
I stick by, I stick by them. I also love how you gave go a six.
That's pretty high. If you asked me, I thought he was good.
I just have you read the manga. I have read the Mark. Did you give it a six?
[inaudible] a ginger Yuto, manga that,
and they made a movie about it like five years ago. I think it is.
I think it was a fun reveal. I had a fun time watching a cookie.
I was so sad watching it.
Cause the thing about guilt is that I watched the anime,
not knowing any background about it, not knowing it was ginger Yuto.
I thought he was just like campy B movie horror movie, which is,
which is which it is, which it is.
But I remember because I went into that thinking he was going to be absolute
trash and I watched it.
And despite it actually being, you know, trashy and it was trash,
it gave me the same kind of enjoyment as you do watching a beat mover beat me.
Cause it wasn't like it was animation because Keogh,
the movie was animated by [inaudible] and man, they,
you could see some effort being put into this man,
but you also got to admit that like the 3d, some of the 3d elements,
I was just like, God, this is ugly. But is that a good thing?
Because that's a horror. Like I don't even know.
In 2012 it wasn't, you know, they.
Weren't very good. No,
it was compared to some of the 3d that came out in 2012 compared to like studio
Gonzo, Gantz, 3d, which just makes me want to vomit.
When I think about it don't remind me like it was, it was good looking 3d. Yeah.
Church. Like you foldable put some effort into that and I,
and I respect them for doing that.
Uh, you watched halo legends. Think you're the only person on my end.
I didn't even know that was an animate by halo.
No IP to the other 19,000 people who have rated this.
I think I've watched, I think I've watched,
that was my stint when I watched that added the mass effect on him as well.
What do you think you'd give halo legends? Did I say.
I don't think so. I didn't, I can't. I I, uh, forgone. Okay,
good. Good. Okay.
I stick by that because I'm on a second season one, uh, six.
Did I ask you? Oh, what's that about? Ooh.
Okay. What would you say? What would you give it?
I think I gave it a seven, seven or an eight. Yeah, I'll give it an April. Okay.
Um, I don't know why I gave it a six. I think,
I think it was because everyone was hyping it up and I was,
I want to be different. I was kind of underwhelmed by it. Um,
now I, cause I have rewatched your own preparation with season two. Um,
I would give it a seven,
but I remember I remember coming out of zero just feeling empty. Right.
And it just, it just kind, it just, no,
because it kind of like I had a good fun,
I had a good time watching it and it just, I,
it was just a gut reaction of it was a good time and I'm probably gonna forget
this show in a few years and it just, it's just, I didn't end up getting it.
So I, you also gave space dandy a six.
Well, I really liked space. I really liked it to I,
if you look at it like a Saturday morning coffee.
But fun space dandy was he, it was very hit or miss for me.
It was, you gave solid online and on.
I like to also seeks God's opinion.
So space Danny and essay on the same one.
Well, top of that, he also gave a guilty crown a five. So would you say that,
would you say the Sao is better, better than guilty crown?
That Sao is better than one.
[Inaudible] be a little harsh on guilty. I was a little harder than guilty,
guilty crown. I would, I would give a higher score,
but going to Sao versus space dandy. I mean,
I rate this based on my pure enjoyment and space Stanley was either like nine on
enjoyment or a two, depending on the episode,
which is probably why I rated it as six. There were some killer episodes.
And then there was some episodes that were just a drag where I sought out on
line was just, was just like a constant. It was, it was a plateau.
He was just a constant six. I watched this I'm trash. I enjoyed this, whatever,
move on. You know what I mean?
Can to explain this one gone. Okay, Joe, Joe seven, what's up with that.
One. Is it the original?
The original one. He gave us six. Which you also watched.
[Inaudible].
You haven't rated any other jurors of a wall.
So I'm going to take us to the Jojo series as a whole.
Okay. No, I rated part one.
[inaudible] I just wanted to get angry.
I just want to get riled up a little bit. You also gave a total row and eight.
Okay. That's wrong? I don't know what the was I thinking,
trying to look like that good taste. Oh my God. No, it's the four.
What do you think you gave koroko basket eight. You did? Yeah.
I'm surprised. I honestly thought you would.
Yeah. For some reason, I think Haiti, I love croquettes. I love CRICO and I,
it was my,
it was curricula was a sports anime that got me back into sports anime. Um,
so no, I, I watched all of them. I
noticed that he gave it a four,
which I would also agree with.
It was just, I dunno, I liked the aesthetic and I don't know why it was just,
maybe I was just high that day. And I just,
I was so disappointed with that because I loved the novels and then just
completely destroyed it. It was me going through it.
It was me after watching backroom and a gantry and go through the shelf type.
I'm just like, this is going to get better.
I, I legitimately thought that Mexico city actors was like the gay porn novel
because of the internet,
because all you ever see about Macaca city action is a line.
It's like a day stuff. Yeah.
Yeah, it is. Yeah. There's a little, there's a large Fujoshi fan base for
[inaudible] city actors. This is a banger. I still listen to that. It's great.
All the time.
Uh, what, uh, what do you think you gave him monster?
Did I give it a 10? You did. Okay, good.
Honestly, I would agree. I would stand by that love monster. Yeah. It's,
it's one of those animates that like I dropped and then came back to. Yeah.
And that I was so glad that I picked back up because it's obviously it's really
slow.
It is really slow,
but I feel like monster is a rarity of an anime where it's an anime that
has an amazing manga that could have easily be sliced up and have a
adaptation. But once there's one of the few Epic like masterpiece, Margaret,
they got to muskies adaptation.
So I mean like thank God it got 70 something episodes that could you imagine
it monster was a 24. That's why I'm scared for 20th century boys.
Every adapted man. Cause that's like monster,
but even longer and even more also, I find it hilarious.
[inaudible] Do you wanna explain what Towson is?
Like imagine,
imagine like the show that birth shows like high school for the dead,
you know what I mean? It is a battle fan service show. And back in the day,
this was the most degenerates kind of fan servicey
action show. You could take so many, like we're boomers, love Iquitos.
It's just like, Nope, your memories. It's.
No, I mean, I look back now and maybe I'd rate a higher, I don't know. It's a,
I would rate it like maybe like a four purely because it's just so tracking back
in, back in the day, this was all we had, you know,
nowadays there's so much trash, anime and trash kind of found surface-y shows.
But back in the day it was kind of like icky, Towson, and then nothing.
[Inaudible] to seven Israel.
[inaudible] I'm thinking back. I'd probably give him an eight now. I, yeah,
I feel like I need to watch it again if you're an anxious seven as well.
I try going to nine as far as season one to six and typical
season to a five. Okay. Yeah.
I mean, I would, I rate it lower now. Honestly,
I would rate it lower now.
It's literally like a lot it's it's one of the shows where I don't know if
the manga readers are right, because everyone talks about the Tokyo ghoul. Mark.
Has anyone.
Have you guys read the Tokyo? Google Mongo. Oh, okay. Okay. So nobody knows.
If the manga readers were right for Tokyo ghoul,
but apparently it's one of the most popular mango out there.
And one of the highest rates they've done much your five go stick by that.
It was, it was sort of in line, but beat us all out online.
So it's all online was like a six.
Sure. So popular when it came out, I thought it was acceptable.
I gave him maybe like a six or seven, some passionate rent there.
I thought it was good. And you're like, I thought it was good.
He was accessible. And there was a big prison school in eight. Yeah.
Yeah. I stand by that prison. School is one of the most.
Like disregarding the ending of the Margot.
It is one of the most hilarious Mongols I've met.
I've read the anime adaptation did a pretty good job.
For five. Yeah. I wasn't sure if I should comment on that.
I was offended by that and I'm pretty mad at him. I've never watched this.
I have no idea. I'm curious. Psychopaths a seven.
Yeah. Season one. Really? Really? No better. No, it's a nine now.
Okay. [inaudible].
Psychopaths is one of those few shows that has stuck with me and it's,
it's one of the shows where I rewatched it and I loved
it way more rewatching it than I've watched the first time. Cause I think.
So good. I think I didn't.
Appreciate psychopaths the first time I watched it,
but the more I watched like a pass, the more I'm just like now,
like I gave it a seven when I first watched it. And when I was doing my,
when I was thinking back to like my top 10 favorite anime of the decade of the
2010s psychopaths was up there. Oh yeah. It's definitely.
Cause it still has some,
like the villain was one of the best villains in the anime.
It still has some of the most unique ideas that I've seen an animate that has
stuck with me. And I don't think has aged at all. Um, yeah, like the,
like the scene halfway through where the main character has to make a
choice that that is, has stuck with me for a long time.
And the one scene that has also stuck with me is, um,
I can't remember what exactly what episode it is,
but it's the episode where this,
they start beating the out of this character in like the middle of the street.
Right. And because of the system that's been set up,
no one reacts just because they they've never seen something like this.
And I dunno, I thought that was like such a unique idea like that has,
that was completely natural in this world that Gaynor Bucci has built. Um,
it's I think it's unfortunate. The world building is like amazing.
I think it's unfortunate.
I think the biggest unfortunate thing is that season two and I haven't watched
season three yet,
but they just didn't have as interesting ideas as Wars in season one. But yeah.
You, when you have like a giant karma taught to like, you know, follow up.